every now and then people binge watching
this show during a quarantine during
this pandemic every now and then I got a
text saying hey man just saw you on
billions saw that show they binge
watching the show it's dynamite saw you
on it and it truly that day of shooting
on that set was truly amazing not only
because it's one of my favorite shows
but I got but I got to meet this
gentleman who's calling in right now
here on this show um he is the man who
plays the fantastic character of wags in
the most dynamic fashion also fans of
Breaking Bad and better call Saul know
this man - David Costabile here on the
Rochester how are you Ben David my
friend I am doing fine I'm doing fine of
all let's just let's start with your
essence what I like to refer is your
episode okay thank you I appreciate that
fantastic work first of all how do you
feel after watching it I was thrilled
delighted but I'll be honest I'm gonna
share with you I'm slightly disappointed
because I actually worked blue for
Koppelman in Levine and Showtime and I
worked blue and maybe they were trying
to protect me from myself because it
didn't make it cuz it make it my
favorite line was and I can't repeat it
here but you know the fight between
Murphy and dollar bill was so terrible I
said that if they made a movie out of it
it would be called Raging Bull s you
know and I thought that was a great line
and and you tell me you you've probably
been on the business end of this cop
Brian Koppelman comes up laughs great
job that was hilarious doesn't use it
you know what happened man
when you get a script and you see what
they have coming out of your mouth as
wags what is your reaction David I mean
usually I only ever twice and I think I
think once in the second season which I
know I cannot say on this program yes um
it was really just like wow I you know I
get to say all the best stuff there is
like nobody gets so never I get all the
juicy tidbits their honor so it's
fantastic it's like okay can you can
well I mean it's it's it's you're fit
right in the role David and having met
you in person you're kind of nothing
like the guy David when we started I was
supposed to be an Upper East Side was
like the man but quiet man behind the
man and then we shot the pilot and they
saw it and they were just like no we cut
everything I did and then they were just
like you gotta go complete opposite no
can I'll tell you I unless because I
knew that Bryan a Dana the created show
I never would have been cast in that
role nobody but them knew that I could
do this I knew that I could turn on a
dime you know just like just attack just
get to come right up and sublimate with
anymore it's about well I mean so it's
amazing so your original character of
wags was supposed to be the exact
opposite of who you are currently
playing yes
Doolittle Godfather phrase okay just
nice and even keeled behind the scenes
sort of constantly Airy to somebody of
Axelrod's Edie and instead you're just
the exact complete opposite now it's not
amazing your character this season is
disappointed because one of your
children has found religion and another
one the poll has it's been described on
this program
[Laughter]
it's funny cuz you're drinking buddies
definitely not David Costabile here on
the Rich Eisen show and you know cuz
again when when we met and we were
chit-chatting a behind the scenes you
couldn't have been nicer and that's the
one thing I took from the inside
honestly the entire it just seemed like
everybody got along and it was just a
fun day a very long day but a fun day
and I asked to take a photograph with
you and you smiled and then I said can
you give me your best wags and then you
you completely changed and flipped the
middle finger at the cabin and right now
we're showing the split-screen I guess
we're seeing the regular you and then on
the right two lags you wait and that's
the switch that you were talking about
then you could flip right there are you
modeling after anybody that you've met
the heavyweight champion of the world
that's right
yes was one I was I rarely get
starstruck and I actually yeah I it was
my the person who does my makeup a woman
she was like go up and talk to him
because I kept I've been for weeks I had
been talking about seeing the other and
she was like don't see him go and say hi
I was like I can't I can't the funny
thing isn't David's that that scene was
shot in January of 2019 and it was mere
days I think or weeks after Wilder put
fury on the canvas here in Los Angeles
and it seemed like fury got way more
than ten seconds to get up off the
canvas and the director of this episode
who's standing next to Deontay Wilder in
this photograph not Axelrod obviously
not Damien Louis but he would like to me
was a Brit I forget his name escapes now
how yes I mentioned to him that Fury
might have gotten some extra seconds and
he was really pissed at me about even
mentioning that in that conversation
yes in our company there's a very large
number of big boxing fans which you
don't find every day you
and a whole group of people who really
love Boston so but we you know we're
talking about it all the time and watch
the fights together I mean I love it I
blocked another kid so I used to watch
you know I'll leave with my dad when you
can watch you could watch it on a TV
like they just did along and then
growing up you know Sugar Ray and Tommy
Hearns Hagler so our work where are you
from originally do you have any you're
from DC originally so do you have any
any teams from DC that are your teams
David it's possible right I traded what
formerly the bullets for the Knicks when
I moved to New York I'm going to
important to keep the Washington
football team I'm gonna keep them wish
which since the 80s where what what how
would that served me and I was going to
keep the Orioles which has also not well
it's a good thing that your careers is
making up for it David well I mean you
take a look at the shows you've been in
the current one billions also you look
at the rest of your career the wire
damages Breaking Bad and better call
Saul that is a hell of a hit list what
was your experience like on the set of
Breaking Bad David I had been watching
the show from the very beginning I was
mildly intimidated by walking out of the
set of what I television show but I just
loved so I was terrified it was gonna
mess it up but everybody again was
incredibly kinda New England generous
and Brian is fantastic in France and
it's just a really nice guy in so Darren
and people were really kind to me and I
knew this role very well and I really
felt like he lived he also sort of lived
inside me this very you know earnest
open vulnerable scientists who just love
science and then sort of started to fall
in love with
it's when you when you get to do good
writing it's so much easier than doing
that ready and that was spectacular
writings work on and it was and on some
level it was it was incredibly easy but
it just had to get out of the way and
let the rain come forward well I think
we've had some of your colleagues from
that show we've been fortunate to have
here on the show Giancarlo Esposito came
on and said a couple of times he he said
he had to take a moment after some of
his scenes that it was it just
absolutely drained him emotionally and
took something out of him he needed a
moment that it did that ever happen to
you killed me that was really the show
of course which was incredibly sad
personally and I had to go find another
job but also just that you know you have
loved the character and to watch these
two people who neither of them wanted it
to happen and it happened and it was
really it was a very draining moment and
Vince directed that episode and so it
was a great it was a it was it was the
we were all feeling in the same amount I
think well I mean it's good that you you
know your character was reincarnated on
better call saw on the prequel and the
scene that you you you are in did you
have to memorize the entire periodic
table of elements I think they gave me
something like six days to memorize
memorize I have a second song it's so
hard i sat and I probably went over a
thousand times and it's just now it's
now it's just in there like you can't
get it out like you just you can't get
it out of your head because you can't it
I also knew that walking into the set I
was going to have to be doing a
chemistry experiment while I was singing
the song and I had to look like I was an
expert at both and yes I am surprisingly
not a chemist and so I was improvising a
chemistry experiment that has to look
believably like chemistry experiment and
sing the song so it was
I almost went mad so I did learn what
you like right now be able to if I
tested you on the pier
my gosh I was just gonna ask you what
the symbol for boron was I mean
literally what's always gonna do but but
you went the extra mile so before I let
you go I mean talk about a gut punch I
for some this is the last episode of
billions until you can shoot more this
is the last episode you shot before the
pandemic 8 is that correct that's
hearing Sunday night no kidding ok ok so
did you did you go up to somebody and
say great stuff and then there it hits
the cutting room floor David did you do
did you did you do that to somebody
there may be in fact some some people
that may have had experience - my own my
own cutting methods but people who are
higher than me on the chain of cutting
so what is it like being a colleague of
say Paul Giamatti and now suddenly going
up to him saying why don't you try it
this way
how does that work there wasn't one
actor on the show who wasn't totally
down with me engaging with them I think
my own experience having worked with
many kinds of directors that often
actors who have become directors you
know how to speak in in a way that is
that you don't have to translate
someone's you get a director do and I
think when you're on that level to walk
up to them and really give them
something that I knew that they could
they could go forward with without
having to translate that are happy to
sort of try to figure out what it what I
really met
and so it was incredible to be able to
for my first effort to work with
world-class actors is you know no nobody
hears that well I love the show
and it's great you are awesome in it so
is everybody else man I'm crestfallen
that this is going to be the last new
one until we can get through all this
and get back to work I love it last one
for you who other than yours is your
favorite character on the show every
word out of his mouth is cotton candy on
the floor man unbelievable that's true
like from the first time we read this
out loud together you just died he's
incredible I am with you and you are you
are one a to his one B or one B to his
one a man just it's great chatting with
you great reconnecting with you and
let's chat again soon David B will well
there you go that's David Constable
right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here